[Música]
el gobierno de Perú oficializó la
declaración del estado de emergencia
para todo el país y por ahora no aplica
el toque de queda la medida que regirá
por 30 días obedece a las protestas y
bloqueos que se desataron tras la
destitución de Pedro castillo y que
dejan varias personas muertas
América Latina es la región más
peligrosa para ejercer periodismo según
el más reciente reporte de reporteros
Sin fronteras la región registra casi la
mitad de asesinatos contra periodistas
México encabeza la lista seguido de
Haití y Brasil
2022 cerrará como el año más violento en
la historia de Costa Rica hasta este
martes se registraban
606 homicidios superando el récord del
año 2017 según autoridades judiciales
cada 14 horas se registra una muerte por
causa homicida y la principal causa es
el crimen organizado Tenemos reporte
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en Flash 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú durante 30
días del país permanece bajo un estado
de emergencia declarado por el gobierno
debido a las protestas que iniciaron
tras la destitución del expresidente
Pedro Castillo por otro lado se espera
que este jueves se lleve a cabo la
audiencia en la que se definirá la
prisión preventiva contra el ex
mandatario desde Lima nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías Explica
en qué consiste exactamente el estado de
emergencia
el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte declaró el estado de emergencia
a nivel nacional por 30 días para frenar
la violencia propulsada por las
protestas se trata de un tipo de régimen
de excepción establecido en el artículo
134 de la Constitución peruana es una
medida Temporal y excepcional que
suspende los derechos constitucionales
relacionados a la inviolabilidad de
domicilio libertad de tránsito libertad
de reunión y seguridad personal el
estado de emergencia impuesto por Rina
boluarte en todo el Perú Establece que
la policía mantiene el control del orden
interno con el apoyo de las fuerzas
armadas para restablecer el orden y usar
la fuerza cuando sea necesaria pero
respetando los Derechos Humanos de las
personas las autoridades peruanas
tomaron la decisión de aplicar la medida
ante las críticas de diversos sectores
que señalan que la presidenta boluarte
se ha demorado en imponer el principio
de autoridad dejando que las protestas
se incrementen el gabinete de crisis le
dijo a la mandataria peruana que se
tenía que movilizar a las fuerzas
armadas para poner control en el
interior del país y sobre todo en Lima
donde grupos radicales planean
concentrar las protestas el más reciente
informe de reporteros Sin fronteras
indica que América Latina es la región
más peligrosa del mundo para ejercer el
periodismo la región registra casi la
mitad de los 57 asesinatos contra
periodistas que se reportaron en lo que
va de 2022 México encabeza a la lista de
países más afectados con 11 periodistas
asesinados como consecuencia de sus
investigaciones sobre carteles redes
criminales y corrupción le sigue Haití
con 6 y Brasil con tres la organización
ve con mucha preocupación el aumento de
estas cifras Pues en 2021 se registraron
48 asesinatos y 50 en 2020
casi el 65% de los periodistas
asesinados en 2022 lo han sido en países
considerados en paz México registra por
sí solo 11 periodistas asesinados es
decir cerca del 20% del total de
profesionales de la información muertos
este año estas cifras junto a las de
Haití seis asesinados y Brasil 3 hacen
de América Latina la región más
peligrosa del mundo para los periodistas
cerca de la mitad de los asesinatos de
este año el 47,4% se han producido en
suelo latinoamericano pasamos a Costa
Rica según el organismo de investigación
judicial Solo hasta este martes el país
registraba 606 muertes y así superó las
603 que se registraron en 2017 que era
la cifras récord así las cosas 2022
cerrará como el año más violento en la
historia de esta nación centroamericana
la ampliación de esta noticia con
nuestra corresponsal Cindy regidor
es el año con mayor número de homicidios
de la historia de Costa según informó el
organismo de investigación judicial hoy
J el número de homicidios podría cerrar
al terminar diciembre entre 625 y 630
con una tasa de 12 asesinatos por cada
cien mil habitantes en promedio cada 14
horas hay una muerte por causa homicida
en este país de cinco millones de
habitantes la principal causa es el
crimen organizado Pues los funcionarios
del organismo de investigación judicial
estimaron que casi el 60% de los
asesinatos ocurridos en 2022 están
relacionados a ajustes de cuentas y
venganzas por narcotráfico es decir por
pugnas entre grupos por lucha de
territorios o luchas dentro de los
mismos grupos delictivos en la venta de
drogas para los jerarcas del oij en el
aumento de homicidios también incide la
falta de empleo y oportunidades que
empuja a ciudadanos a involucrarse en
actividades violentas como el
narcomenudeo otro de los principales
motivos por los que se dan estas muertes
violentas son las riñas y los a las
autoridades de seguridad pública
mostraron preocupación ante esta cifra
Aunque la tasa continúa siendo baja en
comparación con las de otras naciones
centroamericanas
vamos a Estados Unidos en el estado de
Nueva York ya se han repartido las
primeras 36 licencias para la venta
legal de marihuana en los próximos días
se repartirán las 114 restantes hasta un
total de 150 en este año 2022 uno de los
requisitos imprescindibles para aplicar
a ser propietario es tener un negocio
exitoso que tenga al menos dos años de
antigüedad y también haber cumplido
condena por consumo o venta de cannabis
es la apuesta del gobierno Estatal para
pedir perdón por años de persecución
racista por un delito que ya no será
castigado por la ley mamen sala nos
cuenta más
Naomi es una de los 36 Afortunados que
ha ganado una licencia para vender
marihuana legalmente en Nueva York
Gracias la noticia llegó a finales de
noviembre para ella fue toda una
sorpresa salir triunfadora entre más de
900 aplicantes estaba llorando saltando
de un lado a otro estaba yo y mi familia
estábamos súper felices Yo no lo podía
creer le acompañamos a este primer
encuentro de nuevos empresarios en el
mundo del Cannabis una cita que le
permitirá conocer las últimas novedades
del mercado así como elegir elementos de
decoración y consumo para su futuro
dispensario
antes de que acabe el año el gobierno
neoyorquino le cederá un local para que
venda Cannabis
Este es un vaporizador en el que puedes
poner flores allí luego tirar y luego
fumar hoy ha venido sola pero al frente
del negocio le acompañará su hermano
gracias a él consiguieron la licencia
porque era el candidato perfecto
vengo de una familia que sufrió la ley
por la guerra contra las drogas con mi
hermano teniendo condenas y cuando
hicieron públicos los requisitos de lo
que nada más para aplicar yo sabía que
calificábamos así que apliqué
Lo mismo hizo cosmarte que todavía
espera ganar una de las 114 licencias
que el estado repartirá este mes cuando
se enteró de que tenían prioridades
miembros de comunidades atacadas y
discriminadas en la guerra contra las
drogas supo que debía aplicar
en el vecindario de nosotros que
cualquier otro vecindario cuando dices
nosotros A qué te refieres Bueno lo
Moreno y lo hispano nunca imaginó que la
experiencia y sus seis años en prisión
por tráfico de drogas le ayudarían en su
futuro profesional
yo creo porque yo sé mercado bien Yo
creo que me deben dar la licencia
gracias a cosomarte Naomi y el resto de
nuevos comerciantes legales de marihuana
las autoridades esperan recaudar cerca
de 350 millones de dólares anuales en
impuestos por la venta de cannabis
cerramos con noticias del fútbol
argentino ya tiene un rival para
disputar la final del mundial de Qatar
2022 este domingo se trata de Francia
que este miércoles venció a Marruecos
con dos a cero los argentinos al igual
que los franceses buscarán sumar una
tercera estrella a su camiseta los
detalles de la más reciente jornada con
nuestra enviada especial Natalia Ruiz
Francia podrá defender su título mundial
en la final ante Argentina tras vencer
dos goles por cero a Marruecos aquí en
el estadio albeit Marruecos que perdió
ayer de uno de sus hombres claves en el
calentamiento Francia abrió el marcador
muy temprano minutos cinco gracias a Teo
Hernández en una volea imposible que
logró encajar en la portería de Bono
Bono quien recibe su primer gol en este
mundial Porque el único que había
recibido había sido en portería propia a
partir de ese momento Marruecos cambió
todo su sistema pasó de cinco a cuatro
defensas empezó a presionar fuertemente
Y tuvo oportunidades claras de Gol en
especiales en el minuto 44 gracias a él
Yami que que de haber convertido este
gol hubiera sido el golazo de este
mundial un golazo de chilena pero
finalmente el disparo que se estrelló
contra el poste de la portería de Hugo
loris en el segundo tiempo Marruecos
salió con más fuerza a presionar a los
franceses complicándoles mucho la vida
sobre todo por el carril derecho gracias
a ese triángulo de
y finalmente Pues fue la entrada de
colouman y el que la que cambió
absolutamente todo minuto ya 79 gol de
el francés para adelantar y ya callar a
toda la hinchada marroquí que quedó
completamente en silencio en este
estadio luego ya vinieron las lágrimas
de tristeza por parte de los hinchas a
marroquíes Los Leones del Atlas que de
todas maneras lo dijo su entrenadora o
Alice irana a pelear el tercer lugar
ante Croacia este sábado mientras que
Francia buscará revalidar su título
mundial ante la albiceleste eso será el
domingo hasta que este informativo
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]